la croix le jour elle son professeur au
lycée et en élémentaire
amis depuis plus de dix ans mylène et
audrey sont passionnés de chant elles
font leur troisième scène aux 7,8 comedy
club
c'est plutôt des chansons à texte on ait
duo guitare voix et avec des choses
plutôt à écouter et à chanter quand
electronics et quant à l'école et on est
tombé sur facebook sur une annonce du
comedy club et on s'est dit bon ben
voila c'était le format qui nous
convenait quelques minutes se lancer on
se lancer elle les intéressés ont sept
minutes pour convaincre depuis le mois
de février
une fois par mois le tire-bouchon un
restaurant de houdan se transforme en
scène l origine des membres de la
compagnie ou d'aliev l'aviateur sourds
s'est ouvert aux musiciens ou chanteurs
aux humoristes magicien slameurs et donc
on réuni entre 8 et 10 artistes par
soirée voilà et le sait faire c'est
faire kiffer le public au halal on
accueille les novices ceux qui ne sont
jamais montés sur scène et qui veulent
s'essayer une première fois on accueille
effectivement des amateurs qui font de
temps en temps et puis on peut
accueillir des professionnels des gens
qui se disent tiens j'ai un texte a
attesté un sketch a testé une salle de
40 places rapidement complète dans le
public des amis des artistes et des
curieux qui reviennent régulièrement que
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est énorme
et ensuite c'est la possibilité donnée à
beaucoup de jeunes voire de moins jeunes
de s'exprimer et d et d'évoquer tout
leur talent quoi on a passé une super
soirée des artistes au top sur une
diversité c'est vraiment hyper sympa
c'était tellement dans la première fois
que du coup je reviens chaque fois deux
autres rendez-vous sont encore prévues
les 16 mai et 20 juin prochains
serez vous dans le public ou sur la
scène
[Musique]